wearing a mask will protect me from the
virus the problem is that people who
wear these masks usually don't wear them
properly
the corona virus came from bat soup that
is absolutely not correct the corona
virus was deliberately created or
released viewing humans a little bit too
much credit here hi I'm dr. Sara Madonna
I'm the senior director of New York City
Health and Hospitals system-wide special
pathogens program I'm dr. Steven Morris
professor of Epidemiology at the Melman
School of Public Health Columbia
University
we're here to debunk myths about the
corona virus let's get started getting
the corona virus is a death sentence
well there's a lot we still don't know
about the corona virus disease but based
on the data that is coming out it seems
to be a mild type of viral infection
there's a 2% fatality rate and about
eighteen to twenty percent that maybe in
kind of in the critical condition range
and those two percent who died or the
sickest they're in the hospital already
so even those in the hospital have
probably a 98 percent chance of
surviving so it's not a death sentence I
only Chinese people have the corona
virus well it started in China but the
reality is that it's everyone's virus
and if it gets far enough just like the
flu it could be anywhere
infectious disease do not respect
boundaries or borders and for that
matter everyone is susceptible the
corona virus is the most dangerous virus
that is not true there are a number of
different viruses out there in the world
so let's just compare it to another type
of virus so you have the Ebola virus
disease which has a much higher
fertility rate associated with it I
think the official count is now 6000
recoveries but you know one of the funny
things is that we don't usually report
recoveries when someone is discharged
from the hospital
so all those recoveries probably there
are many more on the way as well
wearing a mask will protect me from the
virus a lot of people like to think so
and of course a mask gives you a sense
of security but the problem is that
people
who wear these masks usually don't wear
them properly they've never really been
trained they may not know what kind of
mask to wear so there's two types of
masks one the simple or surgical masks
that you see the general population
wearing and then there's another type of
masks that healthcare workers wear it's
called the n95 mask and it's a
respirator and it is able to filter
particles that are airborne with 95%
efficacy and the one that healthcare
workers where they have to go through
what we call fit testing and so to make
sure they have a perfect seal people who
may think they want to wear an n95 find
it very uncomfortable after a while so
even if it's well fit it's it's then
especially hard to breathe through and
the mask is really for those that are
infected with the actual corona virus
disease not so much for a healthy
individual
so things that actually proven to be
effective is washing your hands often
well you know 20 seconds as well as
obviously if you're sick staying home so
a number of other public health metrics
that actually are proven to be extremely
effective the corona virus came from bat
soup that is absolutely not correct so
what we know about the current corona
virus disease is that it started in
Hunan Province in China in a wet market
or seafood market if you will where
there's a number of different animals
there so there's a couple of different
speculations out there but not from
somebody obviously consuming Batsuit but
what we do know obviously is that once
you actually get the corona virus
disease the form of transmission is
obviously through droplet spread so
coming in contact with somebody that is
thick with the corona virus disease
close contact with them or you know
contact with their droplets right
shortly after you can get sick from a
package sent from China I think it's
really highly unlikely when you consider
the time it takes for a package to get
from China and right now what we do know
is that obviously these droplets that
can contain the virus or the virus
itself it may not be able to survive
outside the human body for very long so
even if it may for example come on a
package or a box depending on how long
it's been there it may not actually be
able to survive outside but we still
don't know closing borders will stop the
spread of the virus these types of
respiratory viruses they don't respect
borders as we know and it's not the
fault of a government
that this type of outbreak is starting
or spreading it's just the nature of the
virus itself travel bans historically
have proven not to be very effective in
fact you know it seems that it was the
opposite they caused more fear make more
chaos people were reluctant to actually
come forward with actually reporting
that they were that they have the
illness a lot of it is perception and
with travel bans a lot of it politicians
particularly I hate to say like to do
that because it gives the appearance of
doing something but it is often
counterproductive the federal government
does state non-essential travel should
be restricted obviously to mainland
China that's the epicenter and that's
where there's a lot of community
transmission but outside of China where
you may see there's over two dozen
countries that actually are reporting to
have corner virus disease but if there
is no community transmission there is
obviously nervous to the general public
but continue to look at Centers for
Disease Control's website they have a
travel health advisory section and that
you can actually go to and put the name
of the country and it'll tell you the
precautions and as well as go to your
health care provider they can provide
some travel guidance to you if you need
to travel to various areas that may be
reporting outbreaks of coronavirus
disease the virus only affects older
people well that's kind of half true it
affects everybody even children the
older people however are the ones who
are more likely to have severe disease
or more serious disease so all of us
older people have to be careful but it
affects everybody and even the older
people most of us will probably not even
be that sick the corona virus is the
same as SARS
so the corona virus is in the same
family as SARS it's a corona virus
disease there are two various and now
three corona viruses known to cause more
severe infections in humans SARS is one
of them
MERS which is Middle East respiratory
syndrome is another one and now corona
virus disease that just started
obviously SARS was more severe in terms
of the fertility rate that we that was
reported so it's about ten percent
versus with the corona virus what we're
seeing right now is about two percent
but still it's way too early to tell
this one is different this spreads a lot
more like the flu but there are so many
more cases simply because it spreads so
well so many more people can easily get
infected large numbers of deaths doesn't
necessarily mean that it's a very lethal
virus it just means that a lot of people
have been getting it and some of them
unfortunately died let's just excuse
north flu for example seasonal flu this
year started in October and the Centers
for Disease Control prevention are
already reporting over 10,000 deaths you
know related to seasonal flu and over
again you know 20 million Americans
being infected so let's just put things
into context the corona virus has
something to do with corona beer know
and beer won't prevent it either so
Corona simply lacking for crown and they
have a crown like appearance with those
spikes sticking up but the beer is all
on its own at it won't prevent corona
viruses won't give it to you it's just a
coincidence my pet could give me the
virus so with the corona virus still
weed you know there's still a lot we
don't know right now what we we haven't
seen any cases where pets are
transmitting the virus to their owners
you're more likely to give it to your
pet than the other way around take good
care of your pads the corona virus was
deliberately created or released
viewing humans a little bit too much
credit here so we basically had three
corona viruses in three decades but we
know that there are a lot of them in
nature that look exactly like SARS and
this one doesn't look special so this is
just another one to add to the
collection infectious diseases can be
caused by a number of different things
obviously they're natural in the
environment it could be due to obviously
climate change ecological factors
agricultural factors human behavior and
these are constantly happening around us
so outbreaks are inevitable it could be
very surprising that anyone would have
figured out a way to create it we still
are way behind nature and being able to
do that antibiotics prevent and treat
the virus viruses and bacteria or two
different microbes so we would use
antibiotics for bacteria for viruses we
use antiviral medications and so for
example with seasonal flu that's a virus
and so
one of the ways that we can treat or
alleviate some of the symptoms is by
giving Tamiflu that's an antiviral
medication so antibiotics in this
context for this virus do not work
unless you have secondary infections
that are bacterial in nature and this is
a very common misconception there are a
couple of drugs now that are
experimental but they're in the
development stage that are showing
promise against this particular virus
we're still in the early stages of the
corona virus disease there's a lot of
rumors things that are not factual so
really go to credible sources go to
public health websites that are credible
go to the World Health Organization's
website go to your local health
department's website or even go to your
healthcare provider to get more
information if you're curious and if you
want to read about all the emerging
diseases everywhere in the kind in the
world you can get on the promed website
or even get email and I think there has
been a lot of fear around this partly
because we've heard of these other
corona viruses like SARS but I think
panic or fear is not really what we need
these outbreaks are inevitable and we
need to continue to prepare for these
types of efforts we need to invest in
global health security a best-case
scenario obviously is that it all gets
under control and hopefully we'll have
vaccines and other things and have
learned something from the experience